[Music]
my name is justin workman
39 and i've been bladesmithing for
roughly four years
the last three months i've been going
through chemo with the hopes that would
stave off the need for
an amputation on my right arm i hope it
sets an example that anybody that's
struggling
no matter how bad it is you can still
power through
my name is doug zegel i'm from mount
laurel new jersey i'm 33 years old
and my uncle was a blacksmith so i got
to move some metal with him when i was
younger
and i really enjoyed it you took
something rock hard like steel
you heat it up and it's like play-doh i
mean what's cooler than that
justin doug congratulations you guys
made it past round one
and two and now it's just between the
two of you with the title of fortune
fire champion and a check for ten
thousand dollars
in round three of the competition we're
gonna send you home to make another
culinary tool but this one's quite a bit
bigger than anything you've seen
and that tool is
also known as the tuna sword the maguro
bocho is a specialized cutting tool
designed to fillet massive bluefin tuna
this impressive blade is not your
average kitchen cutlery with a total
length up to three feet long these
culinary swords are often hand forged by
the same sword smiths that make the
iconic japanese katana
they feature a thick spine and razor
sharp edge that cuts effortlessly
through any large fish
the maguro bocho is still used today by
some japanese chefs
and can be seen on full display at some
of tokyo's iconic fish markets
now when you guys build your blades i
want you follow these parameters your
blade length needs to be between 29 and
31 inches
you need to have a single edge chisel
grind and i also want you to incorporate
ricasso between the handle
and the blade i'm feeling pretty nervous
i'm gonna have to
forge the longest blade i've ever made
gentlemen we'll see you guys in four
days good luck
all right good luck man good
we're here at my home forge in
chambersburg pennsylvania my game plan
is
i'm going to stand my give it a little
flux
the heat treat is the biggest thing i'm
concerned with my goal is to get a
hardened blade
oh i got a nice little warp in that bad
boy
oh i'm so mad this whole competition did
not go
exactly as i planned got about four
hours left of this competition
and i still have a fair amount of work
to do i know for a fact that i met
parameters it's the one thing that i've
been checking
over and over and over again
[Music]
i'm back in mount laurel new jersey at
my home forge and i am ready to get
started on my maguro boko build
so this tuna sword is probably about
twice as long as anything i've ever made
i got to get the forge hot and i'm ready
to put my adcrv2 in there
and get hammering it's pretty malleable
steel so so far
things are going pretty quickly but i
want to keep making progress as fast as
possible
once the quench comes that's kind of the
make or break situation for me today
so i'm just trying to get the heat right
yeah we're in good shape it's time to
get everything
fit assembled and finish this blade
all right got a nice clean fit that is
the first look at what will soon be a
finished blade
now that i have the final assembly
finished i didn't come up with an
elaborate test
but i used to work at a sushi restaurant
and this is a tuna sword
it cut pretty clean
i think it does the job all right blade
smiths
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your maguro bochus will do
i'll take your weapon and make some
lethal cuts on these
six different fishes just in your first
you ready for this
let's make some sushi
way to go man thanks all right justin
let's talk about your weapon here
first up your edge one and done
for all the cuts here it's a very sharp
edge
i like the handle construction here it's
all void so my hand matches nicely and
wraps around it
overall sir it will kill thank you
all right doug you're up next you ready
have at it let's do it
all right doug first up the handle
construction
i really like the way you shaped your
handle here it's typical japanese style
now it's a lighter blade but your edge
is so sharp it cut cleanly through the
fishes
easily overall sir it will kill
thanks
all right gentlemen i think you know
what time it is it's time for the
strength test
now we're calling this our bose staff
attack
[Music]
now justin your weapon is already locked
in our device here and i will be
attacking it
with our waxwood bow staffs this test is
not about what your blades
do to that staff what that staff's gonna
do to your blade
all right you all ready let's do it okay
[Music]
uh
[Music]
all right justin um you know this is a
brutal test for what is technically a
large kitchen knife
but uh you did very very well right
where my finger is there's the smallest
of chips and it's
when i say smallest of chips i mean it's
really small
everything else looks right and tight
all in all you did a great job you
survived
thank you you bet all right doug you're
up you ready
as ready as i can be okay because this
is fun for me
these blades are narrow really thin
blades
it is not designed to take any abuse i'm
already thinking
that justin's got this test one
so dug right off this is a remarkably
light
there is the slightest rough spot but
besides that i don't see any
deformation in your blade as straight as
it was when we started out
it's a good solid piece hold on thank
you
so all right gentlemen two tests down
one test to go
all right bladesmiths we're cutting it
close
we know that both your weapons can kill
and we know they're strong
now it's time to find out how sharp they
are this is the sharpness test
to find out how sharp your weapons are i
will cut through these rolled up tatami
mats
now unlike the strength test this is all
about what the edge of your weapon will
do to these mats
dusting up first you ready for this rock
and roll all right let's do that
right justin let's talk about the cuts
here clearly on
the other cuts they cut all the way
through on the last cut
almost but just a little skin of that
mat is hanging on
but it is a sharp edge overall sir
you'll cut thank you all right doug your
turn so you ready
let's see what this thing can do let's
do it
all right doug first cut just went so
easy without a drag
that it went into the next target it is
a very sharp weapon it's very easy to
wield
and it's light overall sir
it will cut thank you first of all
both of you thank you very much for your
hard work but as we know only one of you
is going to be leaving here the fortune
fire champion
for the check for ten thousand dollars
and today's fortune fire champion
is doug congratulations you won
justin unfortunately you're not gonna be
leaving with the win today and doug's
gonna tell you why
justin on any other given competition i
can see your blade being a champion's
bait it is a beautiful blade
but today your opponents was just a
little sharper a little lighter and
faster to wield
just again thank you very much for your
hard work but unfortunately i'm gonna
have to ask you to please leave the
forge
good job thank you i'm glad that this
time frame worked out
as a dead chemo takes a toll on your
body
but going through that and then do this
whole competition
just goes to show myself how much i can
actually
push through i've always kind of been
stubborn but i didn't realize how
stubborn i am
actually well doug
you are the fortune fire champion
congratulations man
thanks a lot yeah what are you gonna get
with that ten thousand dollars
oh i fell in love with a forge press
i i definitely want one of those of my
own i am ecstatic
you know i put a lot of heart and soul
into making that blade and seeing it
perform the way that it did was uh just
a really great confirmation about my
abilities and it's just making me want
to make more knives
you